we covered the bulk of the policy
Fiasco's and the diplomatic errors of
the Trump administration at the g7
meeting in France over the last couple
of shows and today I have sort of like a
sideline story from the g7 that's just
genuinely bizarre Donald Trump said at
the g7 earlier this week that his wife
Melania Trump has quote gotten to know
North Korean dictator Kim jong-un and
Melania having gotten to know Kim
jong-un believes that Kim jong-un really
has the potential I guess to turn around
North Korea now even if all of this were
true I don't know why we would care
about Melania Trump's opinion about the
DPRK I don't know the answer to that I
don't think we would care but the more
important thing is that Melania has
never met Kim jong-un take a look at
this video of Donald Trump Kim jong-un
who I've gotten to know extremely well
first lady has gotten to know Kim
jong-un and I think she did agree with
me he is a man with a country that has
tremendous potential you're in between
China Russia and South Korea now the
White House spokeswoman later said
Melania has actually never met Kim
jong-un and the the questions
immediately swirling question one is it
possible that it's Ivanka Trump that
meant Kim jong-un and Trump is confused
between Melania and Ivanka he's made
similar comments about both of their
bodies over the last 10 or 15 years
maybe the confusion goes beyond just
seeing them as being similarly
well-endowed or something like that what
was the official explanation because
there is an obvious impossibility here
Trump says Melania has gotten to know
Kim jong-un the White House says Melania
has never met Kim jong-un how could both
be true you're going to like this
Stephanie Grisham the White House
spokeswoman said president Trump
confides in his wife on many issues
including the detailed elements of his
strong relationship with chairman Kim
and while the first lady hasn't met him
the president feels like she's gotten to
know too
why does he have to lie about the
dumbest things the answer is that it
simply comes naturally to him it's
reflexive it's possibly even
pathological for him and of course this
raises the question of has Trump shared
confidential classified or otherwise
sensitive and secret information with
Melania Trump that would of course be a
concern as well and to be perfectly
frank I'm more interested in whether
Melania Trump has gotten to know Justin
Trudeau looking very very friendly
greeting each other at the g7 while
Donald Trump stood aside anyway there is
one other possibility maybe Melania
Trump and Kim jong-un have met and it's
being covered up although it doesn't
seem like the most likely thing I don't
recall Melania Trump even attending the
trips during which Donald Trump met Kim
jong-un all very weird the most likely
explanation is the simplest one the one
that requires the fewest assumptions
which is Donald Trump just made it up
because he makes things up on the spur
of the moment all the time and then
later somebody's got to clean it up for
him but in the words of the trumpets
defenders he's a politician all
politicians lie but at least he's doing
the right thing
remember the takeaway which I mentioned
earlier you can't believe anything
Donald Trump or his administration say
without further researching at first the
most basic pedestrian assertions by
Donald Trump need to be interpreted as
potentially lies until you've actually
got an independent confirmation that's
the real takeaway from the g7 for me